[Music]
ironed out and ready to go yeah we did
some practice runs with that as well dr
mark andre lengua and a team of
scientists at the university of ottawa
are trying to take on one of covet 19's
strongest attributes its ability to
spread
their solution a new vaccine you spray
up your nose the current vaccines
deployed in canada the mrna vaccines are
excellent at preventing severe disease
where they are
less effective is that preventing
transmission cova tends to enter through
the nose and throat a nasal spray could
allow the body to form immunity at the
mucous layer blocking it from moving any
further into the body versus an
intramuscular vaccine like the current
mrna shots which attack the virus once
it's already inside you what
slows down evolution is stopping the
number of replication events and you can
get
good clearance or even sterilizing
immunity when your antibodies
immediately just
destroy the pathogen we already have
nasal vaccines for the flu but they
aren't without their issues sneezing or
swallowing while being treated can
impact efficacy and with little known
about mucosal immunity development can
be difficult michael russell an expert
in the specialization says producing one
will go a long way towards preventing
disease
no disease
no spread if you want to control
transmission by immunological means then
i think the only way you're going to do
that is with a mucosal intranasal
vaccine globally there are 16 covanasal
vaccines in human trials including one
in the initial phase at the university
of calgary three others are already in
large scale human studies if proven safe
and effective nasal vaccines could be on
the market in months right now we're
just working on ourselves langlois and
his colleagues are still in the early
days of testing a nasal spray vaccine an
effective one should be a vaccine that
can be adapted to the various
variants of concern ranging closer they
hope to creating the key experts say to
stopping covet in its tracks
jamie morocco global news toronto